hi guys uh huge congratulations on the
film i thought it was great um
like most of your movies is a little bit
hard to describe so how
do you describe it it's it's funny
because we uh
uh
we always leave the um
the pitching and marketing of the films
away after it's done so we're still kind
of figuring it out ourselves
um i'll give kind of the the genre if
you want to get the log line but it's
it's uh we we jokingly have called
called it uh pineapple express like pie
meets pineapple express so there's kind
of like a stoner comedy aspect to it but
there's also a an obsessive rabbit
hole-ish
rabbit holish um
dark mystery uh to the whole thing as
well
for the big lebowski i guess this is a
good comp yeah
uh and it's it's basically it's about
these two new neighbors
uh who
who observe in one of their apartments
something that they interpret as being
supernatural or otherworldly or
paranormal
and
uh as opposed to running it away from
its screaming which they do kind of do
initially they slowly realize like hey
this is
there could be something to this in
terms of making a name for ourselves and
having some sort of professional success
in life
and and thus they go down a
a uh
a very dark rabbit hole in doing so
when did you decide that this was going
to be your next move i think it was
about
three or four months into the first
lockdown
uh we had uh we had anticipated we'd
think we were thinking we would
um
we'd prep something that right when
lockdown would end we could kind of come
out and do immediately so instead of
trying to make a movie during lockdown
we would spend the lockdown making that
thing super prepared just get very very
ready for it
and two things happened one is we
realized um
the those those lockdowns and
quarantines weren't going to end anytime
soon
uh and then the other thing that
happened
was that um we realized that we'd always
even people would ask like oh what would
you tell a first-time filmmaker say well
go go out and make movies with your
friends that's what we would respond it
was a longer answer than that but that's
kind of the the central thing is like
you just can't wait for permission for
from somebody to go make your first
movie they're not going to give it to
you you just have to do it
and we realized that we were um about to
betray our own advice
where we had this opportunity we just
hadn't yet figured out the actual
mechanism of adaptation to it
and uh and so we got together luckily we
we actually live in the locations that
the film takes place in we're actually
in it right now this is justin's
apartment my apartment's downstairs
and uh so we would get together and form
the quarantine bubble
and uh and just said how can we figure
this out how can we actually
put the skills that we have to work to
make something that isn't just about
loneliness and isolation and quarantine
and viruses and sadness you know the
film has a really big sort of unsolved
mystery kind of look to it okay talk
about sort of creating the visual
language of the film
well i mean one thing that's kind of
relevant to the very much relevant to
the visual language of the film is uh
that is always either aaron or myself
frame almost always aaron or myself
framing a shot yeah
and uh
and thus it was really interesting to
to not be working with a camera operator
and just always get the exact shot in
your head that you were thinking
and
lots of wonderful things come out of the
collaboration with the camera operator
but it is very interesting to work on
something where you actually do get the
exact framing and composition that you
your your gut guides you to
and
something's like there's no r wrong or
right answer but it's so interesting to
see a movie
to see whenever movies finished and be
like that was
just purely distilled
our own gut leading what that frame is
yeah um part of the version the visual
language of the film kind of also comes
into the edit a bit
because it has all these cutaways to
other things kind of documentary style
uh it's a joke we've always wanted to
play once or twice in a film but we
never realized that would actually
completely define the way that this film
looks and feels um
and
oh i was going to say that there's also
the cameras that john and levi have
within the movement
those cameras are framed to according to
how we thought their character would
frame a shot
so
levi often shoots john
very very close with his standard death
camera and john
oftentimes is just
really careless with this framing like
levi's like
face is cut off and it's it's dutch for
no reason and yeah uh
because and the idea being like oh what
levi thinks isn't important you know i
don't need to be careful with this and
uh and so there's
um interesting little things and we can
play with that but it's but it feels
like much more of a risk when you're not
doing it yourself when you're asking
someone else to do it but in our case it
was just it was us and our producer dave
and a lot of those cutaways were
actually also shot by this wonderful
second unit uh led by our direct by our
production designer actually directed it
um
but yeah it was uh
uh
there's so much more to talk about with
the visual style of film to be honest i
feel like you can go down about 19
rabbit holes because the film is such a
particular monster
for sure um
like was uh speaking of also mysteries
that's the whole sort of as you
mentioned the strange occurrences that
are happening that inspired the events
of the film uh how much research did you
go into uh for for the sort of history
that you
present in the film because there's a
lot of
la history built into it as well
it's primarily an invented history
uh
an invented history that would be within
the realm of possibility only in the
sense that this like i'll give you an
example
um
the thing about the pythagorean
brotherhood that john's chasing down
we never once we didn't find any
research into the pythagorean
brotherhood in los angeles now however
that reference made to jack parsons
the the rocket scientist who was into
the occult that's real and he was a
follower of aleister crowley aleister
crowley his traditions were
they incorporated things that were from
the pythagorean brotherhood to some
extent
um western esotericism is based in that
stuff to some extent there's no doubt
um
but that said the mythology within the
movie for the
it's like
it's a completely invented mythology
forms the spine and in that spine
uh some of those bones are real
there's this amazing uh thing in los
angeles called the museum of jurassic
technology
and uh it's a four-story building with a
tea house on the top and
you you wander through it and it is a
legit museum it looks and feels just
like one except what they don't tell you
is half of the things in it are just
made up um and you don't know what half
and we actually uh we're inspired by
that it's like that would be a really
interesting format for a movie um now
obviously this is fully made up it is a
it is a movie
but uh but we're making a movie in which
there is a film that feels like
partially fabricated but also
fabricating it ourselves in real life
paul claude
you had sort of one location movie for
week resolution you have appeared in
your movie before but how was it to
combine the two and be mostly one
location with just the two of you on
camera
well for us it actually didn't feel too
much like a pressure cooker of a single
chamber piece because
only half the shoot took place inside
the last two weeks of shooting we were
running all over los angeles
and uh and shooting all the other people
that are in the film um
and uh and because of you know using
things like compositing and just
alternate history and all of that we
feel like there's obviously this kind of
rube goldberg machine esque mystery that
you chase point a to b to c to d
all over the city
um but it
also comes full circle back into this
apartment
um but yeah it didn't besides it being
the hottest october on record and uh we
were up here holding 50 pound cameras
all day and dying
um we didn't feel like we're in this
room all that much yeah and actually i
just realized something it might be our
most
even though this isn't in the narrative
it might be our most internationally
shot film so yeah
even more so than spring
if i if i just if i
uh there might be like a couple more
international locations in this movie
that we just had to use by circumstance
that we had to be in that place
to pick up that shot after the original
bulk of principal photography
um i also i really
needed to ask about the the score and
especially
the use of the thermi in the in the
music because i was that degrees is such
an ethereal feel to it and it just
sounds
super weird so how was it uh to to work
with the with the composer sort of
picking that sound
it's great to hear you bring up the
score because it's our favorite thing to
talk about in the whole film um we say
we we we noticed this every single time
but because we have our hands dirty in
every little bit of the film and in the
edit and all of that
uh there's there's very little things
that are movie magic because the
discoveries just came from following the
process that we already know
but for us we actually experience movie
magic when we hear our score by jimmy
lavalle he's always scored our films
um because he he surprises us his brain
works in a way that is so
completely different than anyone would
expect
and he knows how to find sounds that we
haven't heard before
and uh which also thematically works
really well with the film you know
there's no analog it's kind of like a
ghost it's kind of like an alien but
there's no exact analog for what the
phenomena are in this film and he does
that with music somehow
obviously
jimmy lavall is mostly known as the
album leaf
is his band
and
you know we've done i believe this is
the fourth movie
we've done with him
and
for one he had more time on this one
to just marinate on ideas and he did an
original he did an original set of score
that was purely based off of the script
and
and then he did another score that was
purely based off when he got picture
and the ultimate score ended up being a
combination of those two things
but
you know again fourth movie with him
for me personally growing up in san
diego he's kind of like like a like an
adolescent hero like he was like one of
the he was like one of the few people
growing up in san diego who was like
there's this like famous musician who
made it and uh it's like ham and blink
182.
wildly different but
but uh
to work with him like we have over the
last four films and then to witness what
he did on this one
like look the score to spring is very
special the sports the endless is very
special the sports and chronic is
spectacular um this score
while there was always a mystery to us
of how he did those prior ones this one
we're just like i don't know he's just a
genius person and and
and like i literally don't know how he
did it yeah yeah like we gave some
direction here and there
but it was
it was like aaron said it was like yeah
that was the closest thing to witnessing
magic in the filmmaking process
you spoke about the sort of you're
shooting a movie with your friends and
the the the end grade is very much
reflect that
that that idea that love how was it uh
or how do you compare going
from something like this in and and
working on a marble project of that
scale like moonlight
besides it being absolutely exhausting
to work on you know a netflix show or a
marvel show during the day and and work
on posts on something tiny like this
where you're responsible for every
decision at night or weekends and all
that
despite the exhaustion
um it's like the exhaustion of like a
great workout you know where you're like
i
feel good about it um they keep you
alive uh in many ways if we didn't have
the other um there are there are times
when
if we if one of the projects didn't have
the other
then that project would have become a
grind
but it never did because there was an
oscillation that keeps your brain you
know always bouncing between two things
so
um
you know when you have a really rough
day in the edit where you make no
progress you can't figure a scene out um
you you had an amazing day on set uh and
um
and vice versa it's just great
besides the the sort of numerology and
all the mythology for the film there's
also
as i mentioned sort of uh very much
connected to to los angeles not only in
the supernatural aspect but also just
the
the idea or the feeling of of living in
the city how much of your own life was
uh put into the character and the story
you know what's so interesting about
that question that we've realized in the
last 48 hours is
um
it's so weird to honestly say nothing is
autobiographical
but simultaneously there's a bunch of
our childhood footage matching to these
characters
and it's very bizarre now to think it's
like well there's these two characters
who aren't us at all they are now exist
on their own uh they're out in the world
uh we have distance from performing as
then they will increasingly become their
own their own thing and they have stolen
our childhoods
he's never used that it's a weird
feeling um
you know what's funny we tried we tried
pretty hard to make sure the characters
weren't just uh avatars for ourselves um
and so so as as he says there's very
little of it but i do remember there is
one thing that's kind of interesting
that definitely is something we both
feel which is there is a hidden magic in
los angeles
a lot of people like to complain about
the city as a as a um
uh
as a place where dreams go to die
and there's a bunch of fakeness and all
that
but i honestly think that's when people
stop looking that's how they start
feeling about about it but if you keep
digging
you know there there's you can find it
anywhere including in the city of los
angeles but there's just very
interesting interesting things and you
can't have a lone encounter with a
coyote in the middle of a suburb
at two o'clock in the morning and not
think wow that was kind of magical
there's a couple of easter eggs to your
other films uh like they're in most of
your films to the uninitiated where do
you recommend them start in your
filmography and sort of get their way
into
wow
this wow
what i think we usually tell people what
we usually tell people is uh it's
something like
the endless spring resolution synchronic
uh
that's usually but we haven't even
considered that with this with this new
one and
there's a uh
especially on re-watch
you're probably going to see an even
more significant connection between the
films and to us there's there's a huge
connection um but we also decided very
early on that it would be
you know if you've seen the films prior
this will be really rewarding to pick up
on these things and analyze it from that
and
and if you haven't they're just really
interesting texture and you just get a
feeling of something
uh developed and big and
and in a world and you just feel it
lastly uh
you premiere uh all of your movies film
festival but is your first sundance uh
how was it when you first got the news
that you were going to premiere here and
is there a film festival that you have
in premiere at that you are like okay
this is the next one
i'll kick us off with saying
i would assume people would just like
know this we've submitted everything
we've ever made to sundance and just
didn't work out never and i never got in
so to to be like oh after 12 or 13 years
of working together and doing this thing
to like get that acceptance
it was like
it like literally took time to process
yeah it was like i took days to even
like realize that even happened it's
like kind of being in a weird
pleasant state of shock yeah yeah it
actually was about five days afterwards
that i felt
the the immediate like the surging
elation
um of of
getting into sundance and it was strange
we were talking about it was like why
don't i feel
i i'm happy but why don't i why am i not
why is my head not exploding i think
it's just because we prepared ourselves
so thoroughly for the rejection
[Laughter]
and it was like another one it was like
oh
um
even though even though all of our films
have had wonderful film festival
premieres it feels just as good at every
single time and it also is just as big
of a gamble it is not a definite yes so
being able to get in is such an
amazing audience absolutely uh was there
a film festival you haven't got a
premiere yet that you
are hoping to get one uh
next
i want to jinx it yeah i don't want to
jinx it
up
i don't know but there is a festival
that hasn't it's called sundance 2. it's
coming in now
don't give them ideas or better give
them ideas
guys thank you so much it's been an
absolute pleasure and huge
congratulations on the film
thank you thank you for taking the time
to watch and
further taking time to talk to us more
you've got to be so sick of us at this
point
not yet